you've seen these videos it's a genre
video that i don't really understand
which is
hysterical women filming themselves
crying
i don't know i don't cry all that much
not saying that to brag you know i'm not
saying that to be
macho here but i just i don't cry a lot
you know only if a dear beloved family
member dies or if i see a particularly
gorgeous sunset and one tear just
wistfully kind of falls down my cheek
but but i will say this
when i have cried i do not have the
impulse
to film myself and then post it on tick
tock
i don't maybe i'm an old fuddy duddy
maybe i'm a boomer i don't have that
impulse
but a lot of these left-wing women do
one
crazy lady decided to film herself in a
bathtub
weeping because a new justice was added
to the supreme court
don't mind me i'm in the bath but
while i've been here i got a
notification
that that uh
amy coney parent was
officially convert to the supreme court
i didn't think i would be this affected
by it
but i'm scared i'm scared for me
other women people
who need help everyone except
white men so um
please vote next week let's try to
do something yeah man white men are
terrible you know i hate those guys
because of their sex and their race you
know that's what makes me hate them so
much because they're so bad
all the other people are so much better
you know isn't that
that's that is what they believe this is
even this like silly frivolous white
liberal woman
why is she afraid what is she scared of
i guess the only right
of hers that amy barrett is threatening
that a conservative court would threaten
is the right to kill her
child through abortion but let's say
worst case scenario for this lady let's
say roe versus weight is overturned
that seems like an unlikely scenario but
if it were then
in almost certainly the issue would go
to the states i assume this crazy lady
lives in
a state that would permit abortion so
she still gets to kill her kid
let's say she doesn't let's say she
lives in the middle of alabama or
something
and so the state is actually going to
outlaw abortion
if roe versus white gets overturned what
does that mean for what is she so afraid
of it means that she won't be able to
kill her kid
and she'll have to you know have the kid
for
if she does become pregnant if her
contraception doesn't work or something
she's going to be uncomfortable for nine
months and then give the kid up for
adoption
or raise the kid if she wants to that's
it that's what she's afraid of
that's the great fear that has her
cowering crying in a bathtub
is not being able to kill her
hypothetical child
maybe in a very unlikely circumstance
that is a mania that is hysteria
this woman needs help she needs a
support network
i would say she should talk to her
husband something tells me though maybe
that's not a possibility
when society breaks down when
the sense of family most importantly the
basic building block of society but also
local
government civic institutions the church
your bowling league your township your
what your state whatever when
all those things break down you are left
as an atomized individual and the only
meaningful relationship that you can
have is with the federal government
so like if this let's say this woman
were married and her husband came home
and cheated on her or you know i don't
know
did sold bet the family farm or whatever
did something
that action would merit that reaction
that is the reaction of a
personal affront in an intimate
relationship
but this woman's reaction makes it
appear that her most intimate personal
relationship is with the federal
government
which i think it probably is barack
obama pitched this as part of his
re-election campaign in 2012.
he called it the life of julia you now
can barely find it on the internet it
was basically
scrubbed from the internet it described
a woman named julia this hypothetical
woman
from cradle to grave having everything
provided for her
by the federal government no husband no
family
no local community no nothing at one
point she chooses to have a child
doesn't get married doesn't fall in love
doesn't go on nope just chooses to have
a child
and then big daddy obama federal
government will come in
and provide for her and then she dies
and she dies alone and the federal
government provides for that too
that's a bleak life i'd be crying too if
that were my life
what is this woman so afraid of
there are a lot of people like this who
believe know that
the supreme court the supreme court
should not have a huge effect on your
life
if it is something has gone wrong both
in politics and
in your personal life i hope you enjoyed
that short segment from the michael
knowles show be sure to check out the
full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts